ja
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
die vom sport hat wieder norbert lehmann
und wir haben unter anderem diese themen
für sie
2g 3g oder impfpflicht neue corona
höchstwerte verschärfen die debatte um
die richtigen maßnahmen
gestrandet vor der eu außengrenze der
flüchtlingsstreit zwischen polen und
belarus spitzt sich zu kanzlerin merkel
bittet russlands präsident putin um
vermittlung
und mehr rechte für radkuriere nach
einem gerichtsurteil müssen sie vom
arbeitgeber handy und fahrrad bekommen
oder geld als ausgleich
schärfere maßnahmen gegen die wucht der
vierten corona welle das fordern immer
mehr wissenschaftler und ärzte von der
politik sogar kontakt beschränkungen
sind wieder im gespräch und die
kanzlerin drängt schnellstmöglich auf
eine abstimmung zwischen bund und
ländern der tageswert der neuinfektionen
ist nach angaben des robert koch
instituts mit 39
1676 fällen so hoch wie nie genau wie
die sieben tage incidents gestern lag
sie bei
213,7 heute bei
232,1 und auch die zahl der täglichen
todesfälle steigt wieder deutlich auf
236 völker tucek hat mehr
das ist kein
spezialeinsatzkommando sondern das
ordnungsamt pirna mit verstärkung zehn
teams kontrollieren ob die zweijährige
die im chinesen hier in sachsen
tatsächlich eingehalten wird wir kommen
zur kontrolle der sächsischen kommunen
schutzverordnung
die wirtin hat sorge dass wochenlanges
zweig ein teil der stammgäste vergraulen
wird
ziemlich schwierig umzusetzen ich habe
viele gäste die sich regelmäßig an
testen lassen um hierher zu kommen die
aber nicht sich nicht impfen lassen
wolle die dann mit höchstwahrscheinlich
wegbrechen christian drosten leiter der
virologie in der berliner charité
spricht wegen der hohen zahlen von einer
echten notfällen situation sie erfordere
maßnahmen wie womöglich ausgangssperren
und kontakt beschränkungen wir müssen
also jetzt die infektions tätigkeit
durch kontakt maßnahmen wahrscheinlich
wieder kontrollieren nicht
wahrscheinlich sondern sicher auch
weil es immer mehr impft durchbrüche
gibt setzt der epidemiologe josef auf
zweig und einen zusätzlichen test nur so
könne man die menschen optimal schützen
wir haben einfach damit zu tun jetzt
dass die wirksamkeit der impfung
allmählich nach dass bei vielen menschen
die vor einiger zeit geworden sind und
damit muss man halt überlegen dass man
auch mit tests neue zusätzliche
sicherheit schafft auch bei 2g die
reaktivierung der impfzentren auch darin
sehen experten einen weg aus der krise
sie könnten helfen schnell die zahl der
dritten impfung der sogenannten booster
impfungen zu erhöhen impfen impfen gilt
vielen intensivmedizinern als
erfolgsrezept
eine ganz massive
impfkampagne nochmal mobile ist alles
was irgendwie machbar es kreative
lösungen um die menschen zu überzeugen
sich impfen zu lassen und auch unser
personal möglich schnell bewusst zu
essen oder eben die patienten
entsprechend zu schützen es wird ein
schwerer corona winter da sind sich
viele experten einig eine schnelle
lösung ist nicht in sicht
gunther love energy in berlin die korona
lage wird jeden tag ernster aber bund
und länder können sich noch nicht mal
auf ein gemeinsames treffen einigen was
ist da los ja hier wird tatsächlich
gerungen um die frage wäre eine weitere
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sinnvoll oder wer das alles nur
symbolisch angela merkel hat sich heute
öffentlich dafür eingesetzt noch einmal
und hat auch gesagt sie führt gespräche
mit allen beteiligten um möglichst
schnell eine mpk hinzubekommen und sie
hat dafür auch unterstützung erhalten
aus der unionsfraktion
deren vorsitzender ralph brinkhaus hat
auch heute noch einmal gesagt wir müssen
sehr schnell haben wir sollten es nicht
noch einmal zu einer situation wie im
januar kommen lassen wo es viele
todesopfer gegeben hat durch corona da
kann sie sich also der unterstützung aus
den eigenen reihen sicher sein sie wird
vor allem die spd länder überzeugen
müssen die momentan noch sagen sinnvoll
ist eine solche veranstaltung nur dann
wenn wir auch konkretes beraten und
beschließen können ansonsten gibt es
nachher wieder nur enttäuschung über die
runde der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten zusammen mit dem
bund und da hätten sie noch keine neuen
vorschläge gehört auffällig ist in
diesem fall dass es hier erstmals in der
pandemie eine grenze gibt die zwischen
den parteien verläuft das hatten wir so
noch nicht das hat sich meistens nach
inzidenz zahlen und situationen in den
bundesländern gerichtet in dieser
situation ist es für beide seiten
eigentlich heikel denn die union muss
auf der einen seite aufpassen dass sie
nicht so wirkt als ob sie sich jetzt in
der opposition profilieren wollte die
spd muss aufpassen dass sie nicht so
wirkt als wollte sie ihrem künftigen
möglichen kanzler und der ampel nicht
vorweg greifen denn angesichts der
zahlen hier wächst der druck in der
öffentlichkeit das ist tatsächlich bald
ein eindeutiges und gemeinsames zeichen
aus bund und ländern gibt danke schon
nach berlin chacón talabani
wie die vierte welle brechen diese frage
stellt sich auch und besonders an
schulen denn bei kindern und
jugendlichen war die sieben tage
incidents zuletzt am höchsten ende
oktober lag sie bei den zehn- bis
14-jährigen mehr als doppelt so hoch wie
der durchschnitt die bundesländer
reagieren ganz unterschiedlich einige
lockern sogar gerade ihre maßnahmen
julia schröter berichtet
informatik in der zehnten klasse einer
gesamtschule in mainz die masken tragen
die schülerinnen und schüler im
unterricht freiwillig getestet wird hier
seit kurzem wie in ganz rheinland pfalz
nur noch einmal pro woche statt wie
bisher zwei mal die stimmung insgesamt
noch gelassen versuche einfach auf mich
selber zu achten und ich finde das
sollte auch jeder machen es ist schon
ein bisschen komisch dass im vergleich
zum letzten jahr wie immer noch in die
schulen gehen der schulleiter ist da
schon besorgt da also bei diesen
steigenden zahlen gibt es im moment
haben wäre es denke ich auf jeden fall
notwendig dass du wieder mehr testen und
mindestens zweimal die woche das wäre
sicherlich für unsere gefühle hier
sicherheitsgefühl in der schule eine
gute sache wenn das wieder käme die
korona regeln an schulen ein
flickenteppich in rheinland pfalz nur
ein test pro woche in berlin
beispielsweise drei
uneinheitlich auch der umgang mit den
masken die aber hält der lehrerverband
für besonders wichtig und warnt ich
glaube dass wir in einigen bundesländern
kurz davor sind die kontrolle zu
verlieren und das ist sozusagen
allerhöchste zeit ist jetzt
gegenzusteuern
die kultusminister der länder sehen
dagegen keinen handlungsbedarf
schule ist kein besonderer ort in dieser
hinsicht ist der am besten überwachten
ort schule vollzieht bei den infektionen
wie auch sonst bei den maßnahmen das
nach was sonst in der gesellschaft gilt
und es gibt keinen grund dort extra
scharfe massnahmen zu ergreifen in einem
punkt sind sich alle auch die schüler in
mainz einig die schulen sollen wenn es
irgendwie möglich ist offen bleiben
wer unter 30 oder schwanger ist soll nur
noch mit bei ihren tag geimpft werden
das empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission
aktuelle daten zeigten dass bei dem
alternativ präparat von moderner in
dieser altersgruppe häufiger
herzmuskelentzündungen auftreten
der verlauf sei allerdings überwiegend
mild die kollegen von zdf heute live
sprechen ab 19 uhr 30 mit dem chef der
vereinigung der intensivmediziner und
mit einem krankenpfleger über die korona
lage in den kliniken in unserer
mediathek auf youtube oder in der zdf-
heute- app dort sehen sie außerdem wie
viele intensivbetten in ihrem land preis
belegt sind
schauen wir an die grenze zwischen polen
und belarus dort ist die lage der
migranten weiterhin dramatisch heute nun
hat sich die kanzlerin eingeschaltet in
einem telefonat bat sie russlands
präsident um vermittlung die
instrumentalisierung von migranten durch
machthaber lukaschenko sei inakzeptabel
viele menschen sitzen in der nähe des
polo russischen ortes gordo fest nur mit
zelten die sie vor der kälte schützen
über die situation im lager christian
sen
achtung achtung schallt es aus den
lautsprechern von der polnischen seite
des grenzzauns es ist die warnung vor
illegalem grenzübertritt in
dauerschleife das feuer spendet ein
bisschen wärmer doch die kälte ist
gnadenlos für hunderte flüchtlinge war
es bereits die zweite nacht in folge
unter freiem himmel darunter auch
familien mit kleinen kindern die
versorgungslage für die geflüchteten
schwierig
es gibt kein wasser keine milch für mein
kind und es ist sehr kalt
europa in der zwickmühle polen verdiene
die einheit und solidarität der gesamten
eu sagt ratspräsident michelle heute bei
seinem besuch in warschau polen will
weitere sanktionen gegen den
belarussischen diktator lukaschenko
wir müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
dass wir es hier mit einem ausdruck von
staatsterrorismus zu tun haben das ist
auch die stille rache von lukaschenko
dafür dass wir die demokratischen wahlen
unterstützt haben und die menschen in
belarus im august letzten jahres
lukaschenko versucht europa mit der
gezielten schleusung von flüchtlingen zu
erpressen in moskau heute neue russische
rückendeckung für belarus beim treffen
der beiden außenminister sie geben
europa die schuld für die krise probleme
das problem besteht nicht in belarus
sondern auf seiten der eu wir sehen dass
die eu keine strategie für belarus hat
das ziel ist unser unbeugsames land zu
bestrafen
einfluss nehmen auf lukaschenko könnte
wladimir putin das weiß auch die
bundeskanzlerin
ich habe heute mit dem russischen
präsidenten wladimir putin telefoniert
und ihn gebeten auch auf den präsidenten
luca schenker einzuwirken denn hier
werden menschen benutzt sie sind
sozusagen opfer einer
menschenfeindlichen politik und dagegen
muss etwas unternommen werden doch aus
dem kreml kommt heute nur ein vorwurf
wegen der grenz krise europa so heißt es
würde seine eigenen humanitären werte
nicht einhalten
fragen wir unsere korrespondentinnen vor
ort und in brüssel zuerst zu anders sie
ist an der grenze anna wie erleben sie
die situation
ja wir stehen hier vier kilometer
entfernt vom grenzort kubica hinter mir
sind schilder da steht drauf ab hier
beginnt die sperrzone das bedeutet dass
ab hier nur noch anwohner und menschen
mit genehmigungen durchkommen dazu
gehören aber nicht journalisten oder ngo
mitarbeiter ärzte können hier nicht
durch wir haben uns freuen unterhalten
mit den polizisten die hier hinter mir
stehen und diese polizisten berichten
davon dass die anspannung sehr sehr groß
ist erst an diesem morgen sind wieder
200 migranten durch die grenze gekommen
und dieser anspannung haben wir auch
schon auf dem weg hierher mitgekriegt
ich habe eine sms bekommen ich habe eine
ausländische mobilfunknummer und da hieß
es von der polnischen regierung dass die
belarussische regierung lüge dass man
zurückkehren solle nach minsk und dass
die polnische grenze dicht sein dazu gab
es einen link der für zum
innenministerium und da stand auch wenn
sie die polnische grenze passieren so
werden sie trotzdem nicht deutschland
erreichen
die situation bringt die eu um ein
echtes dilemma anne gellinek was können
wir tun
die eu hat das problem dass sie gerade
vom belarussischen diktator lukaschenko
vorgeführt wird als eine union die zwar
menschlichkeit predigt aber trotzdem
zuschaut wie an ihren außengrenzen und
migranten erbarmungslos zurückgeschoben
werden seit wochen versucht die
eu-kommission die polnische regierung zu
überzeugen doch hilfe anzunehmen
entweder in form der eu
grenzschutztruppe frontex oder in form
von asyl expertin bislang ohne erfolg
deshalb versucht die eu jetzt das
problem bei der wurzel zu packen und
sich gegen die erpressungsversuche von
lukaschenko zu wehren indem sie neue
sanktionen beschließen die 27
eu-botschafter haben sich heute
überraschend schnell darauf geeinigt
jetzt die fluglinien in den blick zu
nehmen da ist einerseits die
weißrussische staatsanleihen will aria
die immer noch mit aus irland geleasten
flugzeugen flüchtlinge nach minsk holt
und es gibt aber auch fluglinien aus
drittländern wie der türkei und der
vereinigten emirate die immer noch geld
damit verdienen flüchtlinge nach minsk
zu bringen sowie die eu versuchen den
zustrom der flüchtlinge zu begrenzen und
sich aus dem dilemma zu befreien
dankeschön nach polen und nach brüssel
und anne gellinek
eine ankündigung vom weltklimagipfel
mehr als 30 länder wollen bis spätestens
2040 keine autos mit verbrennungsmotor
mehr zu lassen darunter großbritannien
indien und kanada
deutschland ist nicht dabei zur
begründung sagte umweltstaatssekretär
flasbarth das verkehrsministerium wolle
die option für synthetische kraftstoffe
offen halten
lieferdienste müssen ihren
fahrradkurieren künftig die fahrräder
und falls erforderlich auch ein
smartphone zur verfügung stellen das hat
das bundesarbeitsgericht entschieden
davon dürfen nur abgewichen werden wenn
die kuriere für die nutzung eines
eigenen rades oder handys eine
finanzielle entschädigung erhalten
das gericht gab damit der klage eines
lieferdienste mitarbeiters statt die
evangelische kirche in deutschland hat
eine neue führung annette kurschus
übernimmt den ratsvorsitz und damit die
spitze von über 20 millionen
protestanten die 58 jährige
dieses aus westfalen war bislang
stellvertreterin von heinrich bedford
strohm der nicht mehr antrat keine
klatsche
annette kurschus hat es heute geschafft
gleich im ersten wahlgang zur neuen
vorsitzenden der evangelischen kirche
gewählt zu werden der rückenwind ist ja
doch stark dem ihr die synode gegeben
hat der erd- und stärkt er ist auftrag
und ansporn zugleich
annette kurschus war 2011 als erste frau
zur leitenden geistlichen der
westfälischen landeskirche gewählt
worden ihre seelsorgerische empathie
wurde 2015 im zentralen gottesdienst für
die opfer des german wings
flugzeugabsturzes deutlich nun will die
neue ekd vorsitzende den kampf gegen
sexualisierte gewalt zur chefin in
sachen machen ich werde es tatsächlich
in jetzt deutlich erkennbar auch zu
meinem thema machen
ich suche die begegnung mit den
betroffenen die ja hier schon
stattgefunden hat das waren
beeindruckende momente dieser begegnung
die waren auch schmerzlich die waren
auch heftig der ehemalige
ratsvorsitzende räumte defizite ein
betonte aber dass die diesjährige synode
einen wichtigen beitrag geleistet habe
es sind schon viele schritte gegangen
worden aber nicht genug und vor allem
ist noch nicht genügend vertrauen
gewachsen und dafür war die synode jetzt
glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger schritt
die aufarbeitung sexualität gewalt kein
leichtes erbe für die neue ekd
vorsitzende
jetzt zum fußball norbert morgen das wm
qualifikationsspiel gegen liechtenstein
mit einer sehr besonderen care
allerdings nach 113 jahren leitet
erstmals eine schiedsrichterin ein spiel
der deutschen fußball nationalmannschaft
der männer nämlich die kroatin über
einer martin schütz ansonsten auch heute
das thema beim dfb-team kroner und die
personalprobleme beim abend training
musste hansi flick auch auf den
verletzten julian draxler verzichten
damit fehlen morgen insgesamt acht
spieler das dfb-team zwischen personal
not und impft debatte die korona
bedingte abreise von fünf spielern
auch heute noch für unruhe und
diskussionen man darf die leute die sich
nicht impfen lassen weil sie sorge haben
einfach nicht verurteilen und trotzdem
ist glaube ich für mich der einzige weg
aus der pandemie ja dass man sich impfen
lässt die frage ob künftig nur noch
geimpfte spieler eingeladen werden ließ
fliegauf ich hoffe das ist es dahin
ändert dass wir solche themen dass wir
fünf spiele nach hause schicken müssen
aufgrund erinnern
dass es sowas nicht mehr gibt seinen
vorgänger joachim löw wird morgen in der
ausverkauften arena offiziell
verabschiedet
die fußballerinnen des vfl wolfsburg
bleiben in der gruppenphase der
champions league weiter ungeschlagen den
sieg bei juventus turin gestern abend
haben sie allerdings verpasst durch den
ausgleich der italienerin in der
nachspielzeit
jubel jubelte zurecht mit diesem
last-minute-treffer von christiana die
rallye drehten die italienerinnen ein
fast verlorenes spiel dem war dieses
foul und das daraus resultierende gelb
rot für abwehrspielerin felicitas rauch
vorausgegangen früh war der zweimalige
champions-league-sieger in rückstand
geraten das 1 0 ebenfalls durch
christiana die rallye drei minuten
später glich lena ladwein mit diesem
traum schuss aus in hälfte zwei brachte
tabea wasmuth wolfsburg in führung bis
zum ärgerlichen ausgleich zum 2 2 in der
nachspielzeit
das war's von sport dankeschön rutschen
sie ist 81 und gilt als coolste königin
europas nennen zumindest die dänen ihr
royales oberhaupt margarete ist zu einem
staatsbesuch bei uns heute empfang mit
noch kanzlerin merkel ohne maske und
ohne ihre geliebte zigarette vier tage
deutschland stehen an ein volles
programm für die königin mit dem langen
atem bei ihrem letzten staatsbesuch
hierzulande war noch helmut schmidt
kanzler
wählen noch wie jeden mittwoch die
lottozahlen sie lauten 6
8 15 16 22
32 und die superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
auch fast ein glücksspiel ist die frage
wann sich morgen wo wenn der nebel
auflöst wer dazu hat gleich katja
honnefer marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal hier
übernimmt morgen migrieren danke für ihr
interesse alles gute ihnen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das ist heute nicht mehr so
strahlenden blauen himmel gab die noch
gestern liegt an dem tief über dem
westlichen mittelmeer denn das
schaufelte diese hohen schleierwolken
herren dichtere wolken gab es heute auch
im nordwesten da lagen die temperaturen
unter diesen wolken soweit 13 grad
deutlich milder wurde es zum beispiel in
rom mit 22 grad heute nacht wird es für
uns alle wieder kalt die temperaturen
sinken auf plus 3 bis minus 4 grad es
wird also frostig am boden ist droht
auch wieder reifglätte davon ausgenommen
ist der äußerste norden dort sinken die
temperaturen auf 10 bis 4 grad das liegt
daran dass dort die wolken warm halten
und die bringen auch ein bisschen regen
wird richtung mitte und süden es ist
dagegen zum teil klar und da bildet sich
nebel und dieser nebel wird sich zum
teil morgen kaum auflösen in einigen
tälern größere chancen auf sonnenschein
haben sie an den bergen und auch hier am
alpenrand nördlich von berlin magdeburg
hannover münster osnabrück bleibt es
bedeckt das kann auch etwas regnen hier
in schleswig holstein oder auch im
westlichen niedersachsen die
temperaturen morgen legen meist um 10
grad im dauer grau sind es vier mit
sonne an den alpen 14 und am freitag
wird es trocken sein am samstag über
klären und regenschauern die sind am
sonntag durch guten abend